pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieux vous connaissez ce dessert
c'est la célèbre tarte tatin
ou plus précisément la tarte des sortes
atteint stéphanie et caroline tenait
l'hôtel tatin à lamotte beuvron en
sologne entre 1894 et 1906 ça ne date
pas d'hier elle aurait inventé cette
tarte aux pommes par mégarde en la
renversant one oubliant la pâte
la réalité est probablement un peu moins
romanesque
bien qu'on ne sache pas exactement ce
qui s'est passé c'est pas de la tarte
incarnez datant de cette époque et
appartenant à l'institutrice de la
commune décrit cette recette avec une
mention à la fin cette recette a été
inventé par la cuisinière du comte de
château viard qui l'a ensuite transmise
à stéphanie tata par conséquent les
soeurs tatin n'aurait pas inventé la
tarte tatin
mais ils l'ont considérablement
améliorée est rendue extrêmement
célèbres à tel point qu'aujourd'hui ce
dessert est inscrit au patrimoine
immatériel de l'unesco qui en fait vous
savez comment on fait une tarte tatin
dans le sud
tu fais une tarte tu la mets au foie est
atteint bon je sais c'est une banque
pourrie on va pas en faire un plat
à bientôt
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]